I tell the story many times ago first
time I met Steven Spielberg wow Steven
Spielberg why should I talk to him you
know how can I start the conversation
open the door I said hi people how are
you big fan big fan people for me he's a
God you know I said oh can I ask you a
question I just see you you know the
dinosaur wow how how can you make that
movie or how can you make a movie with a
human moved in camera with Dinosaur
together and the camera doesn't move
okay okay you can stop the camera you
can frame by frame but move is difficult
so easy Jackie I just pushed the
computer then okay can I ask you a
question I said what how can you jump
from this building that building I said
more easy rolling Camera Action jump
Hospital
foreign